what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here my old neighbors back here with me
today look at us Tony we both slimmed
down we look good anyway that's the end
of the video we know you guys are
feeling proud of ourselves it's easier
so we are going to watch right now the
battlefield 5 multiplayer trailers you
play battlefield right oh yeah love
battlefield alright so any headphones on
doing this on my next date
Wow
[Music]
shoot the plane Wow
[Music]
[Music]
Wow all the options again
[Music]
bust out like John 1 Wow
man my nipples are so hard right now ah
man I love that it's actually like in
game footage cuz that [ __ ] looks amazing
it looks amazing it's amazing I have
recently got back in the gaming or like
officially this year beat a few games if
you have amazing cinematic quality
footage like that it's a million times
easier for me to be that invested into a
video game from the looks of it I mean
I've never actually played battlefield
but do you get all these options of
playing different things like this on
ground on planes the biggest thing with
the battlefield is that yeah it's you
are actually in a full-on battle fatigue
in a tank you get in planes on this one
it's gonna be World War 2 I'm pretty
sure they're gonna limit you on so much
you could do poor like what a machinery
they have jeeps tanks planes anything
like trains automobiles I mean it could
ride train destroyed like crazy that was
always a big thing in battlefield it's
like you could destroy the landscape and
now it looks like you used to just
render it like oh if you shot at a
building in the fall you know it looks
like it'll fall like towards you or it
actually looks like I'm pretty sure that
it's gonna be coming through is a battle
100 people last man standing wins a lot
of games are implementing them and I
like Call of Duty and stuff when it
comes to battlefield they're gonna be
hands-down the best because destroying
of the buildings and stuff it just makes
the whole landscape different like not
much more immersive yeah like at the
beginning of the map looks completely
different than the end of the map
knowing you and I I can't wait til we
get to play this together online and
lose like crazy
we Larry every ten days I've been on the
right team Julie I try to win a fight
all right it's my team destroying it
just a couple kill some videos now feel
five man I'm excited for this game Tony
I can't wait for you to buy it
listen you're gonna come over we're
gonna strain this because alright guys
well you can subscribe to the reject
nation you can click that notification
Bell to subscribe buttons don't really
work
check out Tony on Instagram any I really
didn't mean just by network I want you
to come to the valley and find me find
him
it's it'll be worth your time happy to
have you here tones